- 양자 정보와 계산의 이해에
다시 오신 것을 환영해요.
저는 John Watrous이고,
IBM Quantum Education의 기술 디렉터예요.
이번은 시리즈의 네 번째 레슨이고, 양자 정보의
기초에 대한 첫 번째 유닛의 마지막 레슨이에요.
지금까지 우리는 단일 시스템과 다중 시스템 모두에서
양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지 이야기했고, quantum circuit 모델을 살펴봤어요.
그리고 양자 정보의 근본적인
한계들을 관찰했어요.
그 과정에서 텐서곱과 내적을 포함한
중요한 수학적 개념들을 접했고, 앞으로도 계속
그 개념들을 사용하고 필요에 따라
새로운 개념들도 소개할 거예요.
이번 레슨에서는 세 가지 근본적으로 중요한 예제에
집중할 거예요: 양자 텔레포테이션, 초고밀도 코딩, 그리고 CHSH 게임이에요.
이것은 CHSH 부등식이라고도 불리고
항상 게임으로 설명되지는 않아요.
이것들은 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지 보여주기 위한
단순한 예제가 아니라, 정말로 기초의 핵심 부분이에요.
양자 정보와 계산 분야에서 다양하고
때로는 예상치 못한 상황에서 나타나요.
얽힘은 이 세 가지 예제 모두에서 핵심적인 역할을 하고,
사실 얽힘이 이것들을 가능하게 해요.
그리고 흥미롭게 만들어요. 그래서 이번 레슨은 어떤 의미에서
얽힘이 실제로 작동하는 것을 볼 수 있는 첫 번째 기회가 될 거예요.
그리고 얽힘을 그토록 흥미롭게 만드는 것이
무엇인지 탐구하기 시작할 거예요.
레슨의 개요는 매우 간단해요.
제가 방금 언급한 세 가지 예제를 하나씩 살펴볼 거예요: 양자 텔레포테이션,
초고밀도 코딩, 그리고 CHSH 게임이에요.
이것들이 무엇이고 왜 흥미로운지 논의하고,
수학적 수준에서 정확히 어떻게 작동하는지 분석할 거예요.
세 가지 예제 중 첫 번째인 양자 텔레포테이션에
들어가기 전에, 먼저 등장인물들을 소개하는 것이 적절해요.
Alice와 Bob이에요, 혹시
모르시는 분들을 위해서요.
Alice와 Bob은 시스템, 프로토콜, 게임에서
가상의 개체나 에이전트에 부여되는 이름이에요.
그리고 정보 교환을 포함하는 어떤 유형의
상호작용에서든 사용돼요.
이 이름들은 1970년대 암호학의 맥락에서
처음 등장했지만, 이런 방식으로 이름을 사용하는 관례는 매우 보편적이 되었어요.
그 이후로 훨씬 넓은 맥락에서요. 이 이름들은
적어도 세계의 일부 지역에서 매우 흔한 이름이고, A와 B로 시작해요.
또한 간결함을 위해 Alice와 Bob을
그녀와 그로 지칭하는 것이 편리해요.
보통 Alice와 Bob은 서로 다른 위치에 있고
서로 다른 목표와 행동을 가진다고 상상해요.
우리가 무엇에 대해 이야기하느냐에
따라서요.
예를 들어, 통신, 즉 정보의 전송에 대해
이야기한다면, Alice가 발신자이고
Bob이 전송되는 정보의
수신자라고 정할 수 있어요.
때로는 Alice와 Bob이 협력하는데, 그게 전형적이지만,
때로는 경쟁하거나 일치하거나 일치하지 않을 수 있는 서로 다른 목표를 가질 수 있어요.
하지만 이것은 해당 상황에서
명확하게 해야 해요.
물론, 이들은 추상적 개념을 나타내며
반드시 실제 인간을 나타내는 것은 아니에요.
Charlie와 Diane 같은 추가 캐릭터를 도입할 수도 있고,
Eve처럼 다른 페르소나를 나타내는 다른 이름도 있어요.
도청자를 위한 Eve나 악의적으로 행동하는 사람을 위한
Mallory 같은 이름이 상황에 따라 사용돼요.
어쨌든, 이번 레슨에서 논의할 세 가지 예제
모두에서 Alice와 Bob을 볼 거예요. 그리고 때때로
시리즈의 나머지 부분에서도요. 세 가지 예제로
넘어가기 전에 얽힘에 대해 몇 가지 언급을 할게요.
레슨 2에서 두 qubit의 얽힌 상태의
이 예제를 접했어요.
이것은 네 가지 벨 상태 중 하나이고, 이 특정 상태가
얽힌 양자 상태의 전형적인 예를 나타낸다고 할 수 있어요.
얽힌 양자 상태의
전형적인 예요.
또한 두 비트의 확률적 상태의
이 예제도 접했어요.
이것은 어떤 의미에서 얽힌 상태와 유사하지만,
얽힌 것은 아니에요. 얽힘은 본질적으로
정의상 고유한
양자 현상이에요.
얽힘이 무엇인지에 대한 정확한 수학적 정의가 있고,
기본적으로 그 정의가 말하는 것은 얽힘이
비고전적 양자 상관관계라는 거예요.
하지만 그것은 직관적 수준에서 그리 도움이 되지 않아요.
얽힘이 무엇이 아닌지로 얽힘을 정의하는 거니까요.
아마 그래서 직관적인 용어로 얽힘이 무엇이고
무엇이 특별한지 설명하기가 실제로 꽤 어려운 거예요.
사람들이 직관적인 용어로 얽힘을 설명하려 할 때,
이 두 상태를 의미 있게 구분하지 못하는 설명을 자주 듣게 돼요.
두 개의 얽힌 qubit 중 하나를 측정하면
다른 하나의 상태가 어떤 식으로든 즉각적으로 영향을 받는다는 생각을 들을 수 있어요.
어떤 식으로든 즉각적으로 영향을 받거나, 두 qubit의 상태를
따로 설명할 수 없다거나,
두 qubit가 어떻게든 서로에 대한 기억을 유지하거나
심지어 어떤 식으로든 감정적으로 연결되어 있다는 거예요.
하지만 왜 그런 속성들이
이 상태에는 해당되지 않을까요?
이 두 비트는 밀접하게 연결되어 있고, 각각이 문자 그대로의
의미에서 다른 하나에 대한 완벽한 기억을 가지고 있지만, 얽힌 상태가 아니에요.
얽힘을 특별하게 만드는 것이 무엇이고 이 상태가
저 상태와 매우 다른 이유를 설명하는 한 가지 방법은, 얽힘으로 할 수 있는 것을 설명하는 거예요.
또는 얽힘 때문에 일어나는 것 중에서
벡터를 사용해 지식을 표현하는 방법에 대한 결정을 넘어서는 것을 설명하는 거예요.
이번 레슨에서 논의할 세 가지 예제 모두 이런 성질을 가지고 있어요.
얽힘으로 할 수 있지만 이 상태로는 할 수 없는 것들을 보여줘요.
또는 어떤 고전적으로 상관된 상태로도
할 수 없는 것들이에요.
실제로 양자 정보와 계산의 연구에서는 얽힘을
다양한 작업을 수행할 수 있는 자원으로 보는 것이 매우 일반적이에요.
그리고 그렇게 할 때, 이 상태를
얽힘의 한 단위로 봐요.
이 얽힘의 단위를 e-bit라고 해요.
e는 얽힌(entangled) 또는 얽힘(entanglement)의 약자예요.
두 개의 qubit이지만, 얽힘의 양으로는
하나의 e-bit예요.
이전의 상관된 확률적 상태에 있는 일반적인
고전 비트 쌍도 하나의 공유 무작위성 비트라는 자원으로 볼 수 있어요.
암호학에서 아무도 그 비트가 무엇인지 모른다고 가정하고
누군가와 무작위 비트를 공유하는 것은 매우 유용할 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 암호화를 위한 개인 키로
사용될 수 있으니까요.
하지만 이번 레슨에서는 이 얽힌 상태와
그것으로 할 수 있는 것들에 초점을 맞출 거예요.
용어를 명확히 하자면, Alice와 Bob이 e-bit를
공유한다고 할 때, Alice가 A라는 qubit를 가지고 있고,
Bob이 B라는 qubit를 가지고 있으며,
쌍 A, B가 함께 파이 플러스 상태에 있다는 뜻이에요.
두 qubit에 어떤 이름을 붙이는지는 물론 중요하지 않아요.
다른 이름을 선택할 수도 있지만, 이번 레슨에서는
명확성을 위해 이 이름들을 계속 사용할 거예요.
레슨의 첫 번째 예제는 양자 텔레포테이션이에요.
이후로는 간결함을 위해 그냥
텔레포테이션이라고 부를 거예요.
텔레포테이션은 발신자가 얽힘과 고전 통신만을 사용하여
수신자에게 양자 정보를 전송할 수 있게 하는 프로토콜이에요.
그 전송을 달성하기 위해서요.
이것은 SF에서의 텔레포테이션이라는 단어의 일반적인
해석과는 전혀 관계가 없어요. SF에서는 물질이 한 장소에서 사라지고
다른 장소에 나타나는 거잖아요.
양자 텔레포테이션은 그런 이미지나 비유를
떠올리게 하려고 붙인 이름일 뿐이에요.
텔레포트되는 것은 물질이 아니라 양자 정보이고,
그것은 고전 정보의 전송과 얽힘을 통해 이루어져요.
텔레포테이션이 정확히 어떻게 작동하는지 이해하려면,
먼저 무대를 설정하는 것이 도움이 돼요.
Alice와 Bob이 관련된 시나리오를 상상할 건데,
그 시나리오는 다음과 같아요.
Alice는 Q라는 qubit를 가지고 있고 그것을 Bob에게
전송하고 싶어요. 즉, Bob이 자기 손에
프로토콜이 시작될 때 Q와 정확히
같은 상태에 있는 qubit를 가지길 원하는 거예요.
다시 말해서, 우리는 정보 전송 또는
통신의 근본적인 문제에 대해 이야기하고 있어요.
Alice라는 발신자와 Bob이라는 수신자가 있고,
Alice는 qubit 형태의 양자 정보를 Bob에게 보내고 싶어요.
하지만 제약이 있어요. Alice는 Q를 Bob에게 물리적으로
보낼 수 없고, 고전 정보만 보낼 수 있어요.
Alice와 Bob은 추가 자원도 가지고 있어요.
e-bit를 공유하고 있다는 거예요.
그것이 시나리오예요. Alice가 Q를 물리적으로
Bob에게 보낼 수 없다는 제약이
합리적인 추상화인 상황을
쉽게 상상할 수 있어요.
예를 들어, Alice와 Bob이 다른 대륙에 있거나,
Alice가 Bob의 정확한 위치를 모른다면, qubit를 물리적으로 보내는 것은
아마 꽤 어려울 거예요.
하지만 고전 통신은 그런 상황에서
가능할 뿐만 아니라 꽤 저렴해요.
이제, Alice와 Bob이 공유된 e-bit 없이도
이 작업을 수행할 수 있는지 물어볼 수 있어요.
다시 말해, 고전 통신만으로
qubit를 전송할 수 있는 방법이 있을까요?
답은 아니오예요. 고전 통신만으로는 양자 정보를 전송할 수 없고,
그것은 증명하기 그리 어렵지 않아요.
기본적인 양자 정보 이론을 사용하면 돼요.
시리즈의 세 번째 유닛에서 볼 거예요.
지금은 직관적으로 생각하는 방법은
복제 불가 정리를 생각하는 거예요.
고전 통신만으로 양자 정보를 보낼 수 있는
방법이 있다고 상상해 보세요.
하지만 고전 통신은 쉽게 복사하고
방송할 수 있으니까, 그 고전 통신을
두 명의 수신자, Bob과 Charlie에게
방송할 수 있다는 뜻이에요.
둘 다 Alice로부터 같은 고전 정보를
받았다면, 둘 다 Q를 갖게 될까요?
그것은 Q를 복제했다는 것을 의미하지만,
그것은 불가능하다는 걸 알고 있어요.
참고로, 고전 정보를 사용하여 양자 상태
벡터를 설명하는 것은 확실히 가능해요.
이 시리즈에서 볼 모든 양자 상태 벡터는
여러분이 시청하는 기기로 전송된 고전 정보를 사용하여 설명되고 있어요.
일반적으로, Q가 어떤 상태에 있는지를
어느 정도의 정밀도로 고전 비트를 사용하여 설명할 수 있다고 상상할 수 있어요.
하지만 그것은 양자 통신이 아니에요. 그냥 양자 상태를
벡터로 설명하는 것뿐이고, 그 구분에 대해서는
잠시 후에 다시 돌아올 거예요.
그러나 시나리오로 돌아가서, Alice와 Bob이
e-bit를 공유한다는 가정 하에, Alice와 Bob이
작업을 수행하는 데 필요한 모든 것을 가지고 있다는 것을
보게 될 거예요. 그것이 양자 텔레포테이션 프로토콜이 하는 일이고, 구체적으로 두 비트의 고전 통신을 사용해요.
이 세부 사항에 들어가기 전에,
가정이 명확하도록 몇 가지 빠른 말씀을 드릴게요.
먼저, 여기서 Q의 상태가 Alice와
Bob에게 알려지지 않았다고 가정하고 있어요. 특히,
Alice는 Bob에게 Q 상태의 설명을 보낼 수
없어요. 왜냐하면 일반적으로 그것을 모르니까요.
또한 Q가 다른 시스템과 상관되어 있을 가능성을
고려해야 해요. 다른 시스템과 얽혀 있을 가능성을 포함해서요.
그리고 이 qubit를 Bob에게 전송할 때
그 상관관계가 보존되어야 해요.
마지막으로, qubit를 고전적으로 전달하려고 할 때
복제 불가 정리를 언급했는데, 여기에도 또 다른 연관이 있어요.
복제 불가 정리와의 연관인데, Bob이
Alice로부터 이 qubit Q의 전송을 받으면,
Alice는 더 이상 그것을 가지고 있으면 안 돼요.
왜냐하면 Q는 복제할 수 없으니까요. 그것은 그냥 기억해 두세요.
텔레포테이션 프로토콜을
고려할 때요.
텔레포테이션 프로토콜은 여기 보시는 것처럼
quantum circuit 다이어그램으로 꽤 간단하고 직접적으로 설명할 수 있어요.
Alice의 부분과 Bob의 부분 사이의 구분을
묘사한다는 점에서 약간 양식화되어 있지만, 그 외에는 그냥 quantum circuit 다이어그램이에요.
점선 위의 모든 것은 Alice의 행동을 나타내고,
아래의 모든 것은 Bob의 행동을 나타내요.
시간은 항상 왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 흐르고,
여기 이 두 qubit가 파이 플러스 상태에 있는 것을 볼 수 있어요. 이것이 e-bit예요.
Alice와 Bob이 시작할 때 가지고 있는 거예요.
qubit에 레이블을 붙여서 어느 것이 어느 것인지
명확하게 할 수 있어요. 이것은 qubit A이고, 이것은 e-bit를 구성하는 qubit B예요.
그리고 이것은 Alice가 Bob에게
전송하고 싶어하는 qubit Q예요.
여기서 이 qubit Q의 상태가 프사이라고
가정하고 있지만, 조금 후에 Q가 얽혀 있을 가능성을 고려할 거예요.
다른 시스템과요. 그리고 다이어그램이 주장하는 것은
여기 아래에 프사이라고 적어 놨으니까,
이 circuit가 효과적으로 여기 위의 Alice의 부분에 있던
어떤 상태 프사이든 아래 Bob의 부분으로 전송한다는 거예요. 유일한 통신은
Alice와 Bob 사이의 선을 가로지르는
이 이중선으로 표현된 두 개의 고전 비트예요.
이 다이어그램을 조금 줄여서 좀 더 공간을 확보하고
circuit를 더 자세히 살펴볼게요.
초기 조건은 이미 설명했지만, 요약하자면,
Alice는 qubit A를 가지고 있고 Bob은 qubit B를 가지고 있어요.
A와 B가 함께 파이 플러스 상태에 있으니까,
그것이 e-bit를 공유한다는 뜻이에요.
Alice는 또한 Bob에게 전송하고 싶어하는 이 qubit Q를 가지고 있고,
Q가 임의의 양자 상태 프사이에 있는 경우를 고려하고 있어요.
Alice와 Bob이 이 e-bit를 어떻게
소유하게 되었는지는 모르겠어요.
오래전부터 가지고 있었을 수도 있어요.
같은 장소에 있을 때 만들어서
이 기회를 위해 보관해 두었을 수도 있지만,
그런 세부 사항은 여기서 관련이 없어요.
다음에 일어나는 단계들, 즉 텔레포테이션
프로토콜 자체는 다음과 같아요. 명확히 하자면,
이것은 다이어그램이 설명하는 단계들이고,
다이어그램이 표현하는 것이 명확하도록 말로 적을 거예요.
Alice는 먼저 controlled-NOT 연산을 수행하는데,
Bob에게 보내고 싶은 qubit Q가 제어이고 qubit A가 대상이에요.
다음 단계는 Q에 Hadamard 연산을 수행하고,
그런 다음 자신이 가지고 있는 두 qubit를 측정해요.
A와 Q를 표준 기저 측정으로 측정하고,
소문자 a를 qubit A의 측정 결과로 정해요.
그리고 소문자 b를 qubit Q의 측정 결과로 정해요.
Alice는 그 두 개의 고전 비트를 Bob에게 보내고,
이것이 이 프로토콜에서 유일한 통신이에요. 다이어그램에서는
이 두 비트가 Alice와 Bob 사이의 점선을
가로지르는 것으로 표시돼요. 이 점선을 그들 사이의 거리를 나타내는 것으로 생각하면 돼요.
Bob이 비트 a와 b를 받은 후에
두 가지를 해요.
먼저, a가 1이면, 그의 qubit B에
X 연산, 즉 NOT gate를 수행해요.
그렇지 않으면, a가 0이면, 그것을 하지 않아요.
비슷한 방식으로, b가 1이면,
Bob은 Z 연산 또는 Z-gate 또는 위상 뒤집기를 수행해요.
역시 qubit B에요. 이전처럼
b가 0이면, 그것을 하지 않아요.
이것은 모두 그림에 표시되어 있어요. 제어가
두 고전 비트인 controlled-X와 controlled-Z gate가 있어요.
이 gate들을 제어 gate로 생각하고 싶지 않다면
그러지 않아도 돼요. 이것은 우리가 원하는 것을 표현하는 편리한 방법일 뿐이에요.
circuit 다이어그램의 형태로요. 요점은 Bob이
a가 1이면 qubit B에 X-gate를 적용하고, 그런 다음 Z-gate를 적용한다는 거예요.
B가 1이면 qubit B에요.
그리고 나중의 편의를 위해, Bob이 Alice가 보낸
고전 비트에 따라 qubit B에 수행하는 결합 연산을 명시적으로 적을 수 있어요.
Alice가 보내는 고전 비트에
따라서요.
이것이 텔레포테이션 프로토콜이에요. 정말 꽤 간단해요.
실제로 작동한다는 사실은 다른 문제이고, 분석이
그리 복잡하지는 않지만, 왜 작동하는지
즉시 이해되지 않더라도 뭔가를 놓치고 있다고 느끼지 않아도 돼요.
그래서 분석을 해야 하고,
그것이 다음에 할 일이에요.
텔레포테이션 프로토콜을 분석하기 위해, 한 단계씩 진행하면서
다른 시점에서 세 qubit의 상태가 어떤지 볼 거예요.
먼저 맨 위 qubit가 알파 제로 더하기 베타 원의
상태에 있는 경우를 고려할 거예요. 알파와 베타는 어떤 복소수든
이 벡터를 단위 벡터로 만드는
것이면 돼요.
이것은 Alice가 전송하려는 qubit Q이지만,
지금 이 순간에는 이름이 뭔지는 중요하지 않아요.
조금 후에, 이 qubit가 다른 시스템과
얽혀 있는 상황을 살펴볼 거예요. 하지만 이것이 좋은 출발점이에요. 일을 단순하게 유지하고
분석이 어떻게 작동하는지
조금 더 명확하게 보기 위해서요.
여기 시작점에서 세 qubit의 상태를
함께 고려하면, 이 상태가 여기 보이는 형태를 가진다는 것을 알 수 있어요.
처음 두 qubit는 파이 플러스 상태에 있고,
세 번째 qubit는 제가 이전 레슨에서 설명한
qubit 순서 규칙에 따라 맨 위에 있는 것이에요.
그래서 세 qubit의 상태를 얻기 위해 텐서곱을 취해요.
파이 플러스 상태의 정의를 대입하고
텐서곱을 계산하여 이 표현식을 전개할 수 있어요.
그러면 여기 보이는 상태를
얻을 수 있어요.
그런데, 이렇게 벡터를 완전히 전개하는 것이
항상 최선의 전략은 아니에요. 일반적으로
그렇게 할 좋은 이유가
있을 때까지 기다리는 것이 좋아요.
하지만 여기서는 이유가 있어요. 이 controlled-NOT gate의
작용을 계산하고 싶고, 상태를 이 형태로 쓰면
매우 쉽게 할 수 있어요.
특히, 이것은 controlled-NOT gate가
적용된 후 세 qubit의 상태예요.
세 번째 qubit가 우리 규칙에 의해 맨 위에 있으므로
제어 qubit이고, 가운데인 두 번째 qubit가
대상이에요. 그래서 켓에 따라 연산하면 돼요.
세 번째 비트가 0이면 아무 일도 안 일어나고,
세 번째 비트가 1이면
두 번째 비트를 뒤집어요.
그런 다음 세 번째 qubit에 Hadamard gate를
수행해요. 결과 벡터를 여기 보이는 것처럼 쓸 수 있어요.
제로와 원 상태 대신 플러스와
마이너스 상태를 대입해서요.
이것을 전개할 충분한 공간을 만들려면
좀 줄여야 하고, 이제 플러스와 마이너스 상태의 정의를 대입하고
루트 2를 분모에 넣으면,
여기 보이는 상태를 얻게 돼요.
그것을 전개하면, 여기 보이는
상태를 얻게 돼요.
이것이 Alice가 두 가지 연산을 수행한 후
세 qubit의 상태예요.
그런 다음 Alice가 측정하고, 측정을 분석하려면
레슨 2에서 이야기한 것처럼 측정되는 시스템의 표준 기저 벡터를 분리해야 해요.
그리고 이 특정 경우에 그렇게 하면,
이것이 우리가 얻는 것이에요.
그 표현식을 잠시 보면, 약간 이상하게
보일 수 있어요. 왜냐하면 이제 아래쪽인 첫 번째 qubit가
어떻게든 알파와 베타에 의존하는 것처럼 보이는데,
이 시점에서 점선을 가로지르는 통신은 없었거든요.
하지만 그건 착각이에요. 스칼라는 텐서곱을 통해
자유롭게 이동한다는 것을 기억하세요. 그래서 알파와 베타가
첫 번째 qubit와 연관되어 있다는
의미는 전혀 없어요.
우리가 정말로 한 것은 텐서곱의
다중 선형성에 따라 괄호를 사용한 것뿐이에요.
어쨌든, 이것이 측정이 무엇을 하는지 보기 위해
필요한 형태이고, 바로 한 가지 흥미로운 점을 볼 수 있어요.
그것은 네 가지 가능한 측정 결과의
확률이 항상 균일하다는 거예요.
각 쌍의 측정 결과를 측정할 확률은
4분의 1이에요. 특히,
알파와 베타에 대한 의존성은
전혀 없어요.
우리가 분리한 표준 기저 벡터에 텐서곱된
벡터의 유클리드 놈의 제곱을 계산하면 각 경우에 볼 수 있어요.
각 경우에 4분의 1을 얻어요. 2분의 1을 제곱하면
알파의 절대값 제곱
더하기 베타의 절대값 제곱이 1이 되니까,
각 경우에 4분의 1을 얻게 돼요.
이 다른 결과들의 확률이 Alice가
전송하고 싶어하는 qubit에 어떤 식으로든 의존하지 않는다는 것은 실제로 꽤 중요해요.
임의의 상태가 여기 위에서 들어와서 여기 아래로 나오는데
측정이 그 상태에 대한 정보를 드러낸다는 것은 있을 수 없어요.
임의의 양자 상태에 대한 정보를 얻으려면,
일반적으로 그 상태를 교란시켜야 해요.
여기 다른 결과들의 확률뿐만 아니라,
각 가능한 측정 결과에 조건부인
세 qubit의 상태도 설명하는
표가 있어요.
다른 표준 기저 상태에 텐서곱된 벡터를
정규화하여 이것을 얻지만, 이 경우에는 쉬워요.
단위 벡터를 얻기 위해 2분의 1
인수를 제거하면 돼요.
Alice가 측정한 직후에 있는 것은
Alice가 두 개의 균일한 무작위 비트를 가지고 있다는 거예요. 그게 전부예요.
특히, 그녀는 더 이상 원래 상태를
가지고 있지 않고, 그것에 대한 정보도 없어요. 그냥 무작위 비트만 있어요.
Bob의 상태는 이제 알파와 베타
그리고 측정 결과에 의존해요.
잠깐 Alice가 아직 측정 결과를 보내지 않아서
Bob이 측정 결과를 모른다고 상상하면,
그는 자신의 qubit를 측정해서 알파와
베타에 대한 어떤 정보도 얻을 수 없을 거예요.
여기 있는 이 네 가지 가능성은 알파와
베타에 대한 어떤 정보도 측정을 통해
결코 얻을 수 없도록 충분히
뒤섞여 있어요. 그것은 직관적 수준에서 사실이어야 해요. 그렇지 않으면 빛보다 빠른 통신이 될 테니까요.
Alice는 아무것도 보내지 않고서
Bob에게 정보를 전달할 수는 없어요. 하지만 물론 Alice는 측정 결과를
Bob에게 보내요. 그래서 Bob이 연산을
수행하면 무슨 일이 일어나는지 보기 위해 표를 확장해 봐요.
이 열에는 이전에 관찰한 것처럼 각 가능한
측정 결과에 대해 Bob이 효과적으로 수행하는 다른 연산이 있어요.
그리고 하나씩 그 연산을 첫 번째인
Bob의 qubit B에 적용하면,
네 가지 경우 모두에서 같은 결과를 얻고,
그 결과는 원래 상태예요.
qubit Q의 원래 상태가 B로
성공적으로 텔레포트되었어요.
Bob이 자신의 qubit 이름을 Q로 바꾸고 싶다면
물론 그렇게 해도 돼요. 요점은 이제 그가 원래 상태를 가지고 있다는 거예요.
Alice가 가지고 있던 것을요. 그리고 당연히
Alice는 더 이상 그것을 가지고 있지 않아요.
또한 e-bit가 이 과정을 통해 효과적으로
소진되었다는 점도 주목하세요. 텔레포테이션에는 비용이 있고
그 비용은 하나의 e-bit와 두 개의 고전 비트
통신이에요. 프로토콜이 끝나면 e-bit는 사라져요.
이제 맨 위 qubit가 알파 곱하기 켓 제로
더하기 베타 곱하기 켓 원의 양자 상태에 있다는
가정 하에 텔레포테이션 프로토콜이
올바르게 작동한다는 것을 확인했어요.
하지만 맨 위 qubit가 여기 화면에 있는
추가 qubit 같은 다른 시스템과 얽혀 있으면
어떻게 될까요? 그런 상황에서
텔레포테이션을 사용하고 싶을 수 있어요.
Alice와 Bob이 실제로 텔레포테이션을
100번 수행할 계획이어서 Alice가
100 qubit 양자 레지스터를
한 번에 한 qubit씩 Bob에게 전송할 수도 있어요.
또는 이 추가 qubit들이 Alice의 소유가
전혀 아닐 수도 있고, 다른 누군가가 가지고 있을 수도 있어요. 어쩌면 Alice는 그것들이 존재하는지도 몰라요.
질문은, 텔레포트되는 qubit가 다른 시스템과
얽혀 있어도 텔레포테이션이 여전히 작동하느냐는 거예요.
여기서, qubit Q와 우리가 고려하는 추가 시스템의
상태는 여기 위에 보이는 것처럼 표현돼요.
감마 제로와 감마 원은 이 추가 시스템의
양자 상태를 나타내는 단위 벡터예요.
결합 시스템의 임의의 상태를
항상 이런 식으로 쓸 수 있어요.
여기서 알파와 베타가 실제로 필요하지는 않지만,
포함하면 감마 제로와 감마 원을 단위 벡터로 취할 수 있고
이미 고려한 더 간단한 경우와의
연결을 더 투명하게 만들 수 있어요.
이미 했던 것과 비슷한 분석을 할 수 있지만,
이번에는 이 추가 시스템도 함께 추적해요.
추가 시스템이 있어서 조금 더 복잡하지만,
아이디어는 정확히 같아요. 여기 아주 빠른 요약이에요.
이것이 초기 상태이고, 이것은
controlled-NOT gate 이후의 상태예요.
그리고 이것은 Hadamard 연산
이후의 상태예요.
이것들을 전개하면, 그 상태를
여기 보이는 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요.
이것은 Alice의 측정 직전의 상태이고,
이전과 같이 가능성들을 살펴보면
Bob이 적용해야 하는 연산을
적용했을 때 무슨 일이 일어나는지 고려하면,
실제로 올바른 상태가 나오고
프로토콜이 예상대로 작동한다는 것을 알게 돼요.
이 표에서는 이 추가 시스템을 가리키기 위해
문자 R을 사용하고 있어요. 꽤 간단한 트릭을 사용하고 있다는 것을 볼 수 있어요.
적어도 일시적으로 시스템 순서를
B, R, A, Q로 하기로 결정한 거예요.
그것이 여기 상태들을 적는 데
더 편리하니까요.
다이어그램에 따르면 시스템은
B, A, Q, R 순서로 되어야 하지만,
명확하게 하는 한, 더 편리한
다른 순서를 선택할 수 있어요.
요약하자면, 이 분석에서 일어나는 모든 것은
더 간단한 분석에서 일어난 것과 같아요.
하지만 기본적으로 따라오는 이 추가 벡터,
감마 제로와 감마 원이 있을 뿐이에요.
알파 인수가 있을 때는 항상 감마 제로가 있고,
베타 인수가 있을 때는 감마 원이 있어요. 결국 모든 것이 올바르게 맞아요.
이것은 사실 전혀 놀랍지 않아요. 임의의 양자 상태에 있는
qubit에 대해 항등 연산처럼 작동하는 물리적 과정이 있고,
그것이 일어날 수 있는 방법은 단 하나뿐이에요.
그 연산이 항등 연산이라는 거예요.
이것은 양자 정보의 일반적 공식화를 사용하면
설명하기가 조금 더 쉽지만, 요점은 선형성에 의해
이 추가 분석을 할 필요가
정말 없었다는 거예요.
텔레포테이션이 고립된 단일 qubit에 대해
올바르게 작동한다는 것을 알면, 프로토콜이 하는 것을 설명할 수 있는 가능한 것은
단 하나뿐이라고 결론 내릴 수 있어요. 그것은
항등 연산을 구현한다는 것이에요. qubit가 여기로 들어와서
여기로 나오는 거예요. 사실상 완벽한
무잡음 양자 채널로 작동해요.
레슨의 두 번째 예제인 초고밀도 코딩으로
넘어가기 전에 텔레포테이션에 대한 빠른 몇 가지 말씀이에요.
먼저, 텔레포테이션은 양자 정보의 응용이 아니라
프로토콜이라는 것을 명확히 하는 것이 중요하다고 생각해요.
구체적으로 양자 통신을 수행하기 위한
프로토콜이에요.
제가 설명한 텔레포테이션이 유용하려면,
양자 통신을 수행할 이유가 있어야 해요.
둘째로, 텔레포테이션이 언젠가 양자 정보를
전달하는 표준적인 방법이 될 수 있다고 추측하는 것은 합리적이에요.
그리고 구체적으로 얽힘 증류라는 과정이
잠재적으로 사용될 수 있어요.
qubit를 신뢰성 있게 전달하는 방법으로요. Alice와 Bob이
양자 정보를 전달할 것을 알고 있거나 전달할 필요가 있다면,
이 얽힘 증류 과정을 사용하여 더 많은 수의
잡음이 있는 e-bit를 더 적은 수의 고품질 e-bit로 변환할 수 있어요.
그런 다음 무잡음 또는 거의 무잡음
텔레포테이션에 사용될 수 있어요.
아이디어는 얽힘 증류 과정이 어떤 의미에서
덜 민감하다는 거예요. 손실을 받아들일 수 있고, 잘 안 되면
다시 시도하면 되는 반면, 전달하고 싶은 실제 qubit은
훨씬 더 소중하다고 간주될 수 있어요.
물론, 이것은 모두 추측이지만, 요점은 텔레포테이션이
매우 실용적인 방법이 될 수 있는 상황을 가정하는 것이
어렵지 않다는 거예요.
qubit를 전달하기 위한요.
텔레포테이션에 대한 마지막 요점은
텔레포테이션의 이면에 있는 아이디어와 작동 방식이 꽤 근본적이라는 거예요.
양자 정보와 계산에서, 텔레포테이션은 정말로
양자 정보 이론의 초석이고, 변형들이
자주 등장해요. 한 가지 예를 들면,
텔레포테이션을 사용하여 다른 quantum gate를 구현하는 제안이 있는데,
다른 초기 상태와 측정을 선택해서
결과가 통신이 아니라
선택한 연산을 적용하는 것이
되게 하는 거예요.
다음 예제는 초고밀도 코딩이에요.
양자 텔레포테이션처럼 초고밀도 코딩은 프로토콜이고,
달성하는 것은 텔레포테이션과 상보적이에요.
텔레포테이션이 e-bit와 두 개의 고전 비트
통신을 사용하여 하나의 qubit를 전송할 수 있게 하는 반면,
초고밀도 코딩은 e-bit와 하나의 qubit
양자 통신을 사용하여 두 개의 고전 비트를 전송할 수 있게 해요.
간단히 말해서, 초고밀도 코딩은 고전 정보의
전송을 가능하게 하고, 초고밀도 코딩이라고 불리는 이유는
단일 qubit에 두 개의 고전 비트
통신을 담을 수 있게 하기 때문이에요.
하지만 이것을 달성하려면
e-bit를 소진해야 해요.
여기 설정에 대한 더 정확한
설명이 있어요.
다시 한번, Alice와 Bob이 있는데, Alice가 발신자이고
Bob이 수신자예요. 이번에 Alice는 두 개의 고전 비트를
Bob에게 보내고 싶어해요.
Alice는 Bob에게 단일 qubit를 보낼 수 있고, Alice와 Bob은
작업을 수행하는 데 도움이 되는 e-bit를 공유하고 있어요.
Bob이 두 개의 고전 비트를
받는 것이 작업이에요.
이 작업은 텔레포테이션이 달성하는 것보다
덜 흥미로워 보일 수 있어요.
특히 qubit를 보내는 것이 고전 비트를 보내는 것보다
상당히 더 어렵거나 도전적이라고 본다면요.
그것은 꽤 합리적인 관점이지만,
이것이 가능하다는 것은 확실히 흥미로워요.
이것이 흥미로운 한 가지 이유는 e-bit를
사용하지 않고 단일 qubit를 사용하여 두 개의 고전 비트 정보를 전송하는
이 작업을 수행하는 것이
사실 불가능하기 때문이에요.
이것은 Holevo의 정리라는
유명한 정리 덕분에 알고 있어요.
Holevo의 정리는 이것보다 더 일반적이고,
정확한 진술은 다소 기술적이고 설명이 필요하지만,
한 가지 함의는 양자 통신만으로는
더 적은 수의 qubit를 사용하여 어떤 수의 고전 비트 통신도 전송할 수 없다는 거예요.
e-bit 없이 qubit를 사용하여 두 개의 고전 비트
정보를 신뢰성 있게 전송하고 싶다면,
두 개의 qubit를 보내야 하니까, 전송하고 싶은
비트를 저장해서 보내는 것이나 마찬가지예요.
초고밀도 코딩이 흥미로운 또 다른 이유는
텔레포테이션과의 밀접한 상보적 관계 때문이에요. 이것에 대해서는
조금 후에 다시 돌아올 거예요. 여기 초고밀도 코딩
프로토콜의 quantum circuit 설명이 있어요.
이번에는 모든 단계를 나열하지 않고,
circuit 다이어그램 설명으로만 할게요.
보시다시피, 다시 Alice와 Bob이 있고,
Alice가 위에 있고 Bob이 아래에 있어요.
여기 Alice와 Bob 사이에 처음에 공유되는
e-bit가 있는데, 프로토콜이 실행되기 전에 어떻게든 설정된 거예요.
Alice는 두 개의 고전 비트 A와 B를 가지고 있어요.
여기 위에서 볼 수 있고, circuit가 설명하는 프로토콜을 통해 이 두 고전 비트가
Bob의 손에 들어가게 돼요.
Alice와 Bob 사이의 선을 가로지르는
qubit는 하나뿐이고, 물론 고전 비트가 보내지는 것은 없어요.
두 개의 고전 비트의 전송이
프로토콜의 요점이니까요.
텔레포테이션에서 사용된 것과 정확히 같은 구성 요소를
가지고 있다는 것도 알 수 있어요. controlled-NOT gate, Hadamard gate,
그리고 고전 비트에 의해 제어되는
Z와 X-gate가 있어요.
하지만 배열이 다르니까, 어떻게 작동하는지
분석으로 넘어가 봐요.
초고밀도 코딩이 어떻게 작동하는지 분석하기 위해,
분석의 핵심인 벨 기저를 먼저 적는 것부터 시작해요.
먼저 Alice의 행동이 파이 플러스 상태에 미치는
효과를 살펴볼 건데, Alice가 보내고 싶은 비트에 따라
이 파이 플러스 상태를 네 가지
벨 상태 중 하나로 변환한다는 것을 볼 거예요.
무슨 일이 일어나는지 추적할 수 있도록
표를 적어 봐요.
먼저, A와 B가 둘 다 0이면, Z-gate도 X-gate도
적용되지 않으니까 Alice의 행동은 아무것도 하지 않아요.
즉, 파이 플러스가 파이 플러스로
매핑돼요.
여기 보이는 것처럼 방정식으로도 표현할 수 있어요.
Alice의 qubit에는 아무 일도 일어나지 않고 Bob의 qubit에도 아무 일도 일어나지 않아요.
아무것도 하지 않는 것은
항등 행렬로 표현돼요.
이제, A가 0이고 B가 1이면 어떻게 될까요?
B가 1이니까 Z-gate를 적용하고,
A가 0이니까 X-gate는 적용하지 않아요.
전체적인 효과는 Alice가 Z-gate를 수행하는 거예요.
Alice는 위에 있으니까 오른쪽에 있지만,
이 특정 경우에는 실제로 차이가 없어요. 효과는
파이 플러스 상태가 파이 마이너스로 매핑되는 거예요.
Z-gate가 어떻게 작동하는지 기억한다면 이 표현식에서 눈으로 볼 수 있어요.
이것을 표에 추가할 수 있어요. 두 가지 경우가 더 남았는데,
A가 1이고 B가 0이면,
Alice는 X-gate를 수행하고 그것이
파이를 카이 플러스로 변환해요. A가 1이고 B가 1이면,
Alice는 Z를 한 다음 X를 수행하고
카이 마이너스를 얻어요.
우리의 표는 네 가지 가능한 경우에 무슨 일이 일어나는지
말해 주고, 그것은 Alice가 효과적으로 어떤 것을 선택한다는 거예요.
네 가지 벨 상태 중 어떤 것을 Bob과
공유할지를요. 그녀는 자신의 qubit만으로 선택할 자유가 있고
그것은 얽힘의 꽤 흥미로운
측면이에요.
Alice는 그런 다음 자신의 qubit를 Bob에게 보내요.
이 시점에서 Bob은 네 가지 벨 상태 중 하나를 가지고 있고 어떤 것인지만 알아내면
비트를 복구할 수 있어요.
그리고 다이어그램에 있는 것처럼 controlled-NOT gate
다음에 Hadamard gate가 올바른 일을 하는지 확인할 수 있어요.
자세히 하나하나 다루지는 않겠지만,
직접 해보시면 효과가 여기 표에 보이는 것과 같다는 것을 알게 될 거예요.
이것을 확인하는 한 가지 방법은
단순히 계산하는 거예요. 또는, 우리가 이전 레슨에서 이것을 역순으로
이미 했다는 것을 인식할 수 있어요. 이전 레슨에서는
Hadamard gate가 먼저 오고 controlled-NOT gate가 두 번째였어요.
그리고 그 circuit가 표준 기저 상태를 벨 상태로
매핑하는 것을 봤는데, 한 경우에 성가신 마이너스 부호가 있었어요.
gate의 순서를 바꾸고 이 두 gate가
모두 자기 자신의 역이라는 사실을 고려하면, 역을 얻게 돼요.
그래서 이 경우에 있는 것은 작용이 반대 방향으로
가고, 마이너스 부호는 어느 쪽에 있든 상관없지만
그 외에는 제자리에 있어요. 이 시점에서 측정이
올바른 값을 드러낸다는 것은 즉각적이에요.
여기 마이너스 부호는 우리를 방해하지 않아요.
이 경우에 1이 확률 1로 나타나니까요. 분석은 이것이 전부예요.
한마디로, Alice가 벨 상태를 고르고
Bob이 어떤 것인지 알아내는 거예요.
초고밀도 코딩에 대해 넘어가기 전에
간단한 몇 가지 말씀이에요. 먼저, 초고밀도 코딩이
고전 정보를 전송하는 수단으로
유용하거나 실용적이 될 가능성은 아마 없다는 것을 인정해야 해요.
고전 통신은 매우 저렴하고
qubit를 물리적으로 보내는 것은 적어도 도전적이에요.
그것이 그런 한, 초고밀도 코딩으로부터
어떤 실용적 이점도 기대하지 않을 거예요.
하지만 실용적이 아닐 가능성이 있다고 해서
초고밀도 코딩이 흥미롭지 않다는 뜻은 아니에요.
사실 매우 흥미로워요. 하나는,
기저에 있는 아이디어가 정말 꽤 근본적이에요.
기저에 있는 아이디어란, Alice가 Bob과
벨 상태를 공유하면,
그녀는 혼자서 그 상태를 자신이 선택하는 다른 어떤
벨 상태로든 변경할 수 있다는 거예요. Bob의 도움이 전혀 필요 없어요.
이것은 벨 상태에 관한 구체적인 예이지만,
더 일반적인 기저 아이디어가 있어요. 한 플레이어가
다른 플레이어와 공유하는 얽힌 상태를 변환할
자유에 관한 것이고, 그 자유가 정확히 무엇인지 이해하는 것은
양자 정보를 이해하는 데 중요한 단계이고,
그 자유를 간단하고 우아한 용어로 정확히 어떻게 설명하는지
시리즈의 세 번째 유닛에서
볼 거예요.
초고밀도 코딩은 또한 얽힘으로 할 수 있는 것의
구체적인 예를 제공해요. 단일 qubit를 보내서 두 개의 고전 비트를 전송할 수 있게 하는 거예요.
이미 언급했듯이, 이것은 Holevo의 정리에 의해
얽힘 없이는 증명 가능하게 불가능해요.
텔레포테이션과 초고밀도 코딩을 함께 고려하면,
이것들이 동치를 확립한다는 것을 알 수 있어요.
하나의 qubit 양자 통신과 두 비트의
고전 통신 사이의 동치예요.
하나의 e-bit를 소비할 의향이 있다면,
효과적으로 하나를 다른 것으로 변환할 수 있어요.
텔레포테이션은 두 개의 고전 비트 통신을 사용하여
하나의 qubit를 전달할 수 있게 하고, 초고밀도 코딩은 반대 방향으로 가서
하나의 qubit 양자 통신을 사용하여
두 개의 고전 비트 통신을 가능하게 해요.
하지만 e-bit를 소비하지 않으면, 어느 것도
다른 것으로 변환할 수 없어요. 이것을 가능하게 하는 것은 얽힘이에요.
이번 레슨에서 다룰 세 번째이자 마지막 예제는
프로토콜이 아니라 CHSH 게임이라는 게임이에요.
이 맥락에서 게임이라고 하면, 재미나
스포츠를 위해 하는 것을 말하는 게 아니라
예를 들어 게임 이론의 의미에서
수학적 추상화를 말하는 거예요.
게임의 수학적 추상화는 경제학과 컴퓨터 과학
등에서 매우 흔하게 연구되고, 그 추상화에는
상당한 가치가 있어요. 게임이 항상
재미있는 것만은 아닌 거예요.
물론 그것들에 대해
생각하는 것은 재미있지만요.
이 특정 경우에 우리가 가진 것은 본질적으로
게임으로 꽤 직관적으로 설명할 수 있는 사고 실험이에요.
CHSH라는 글자는 저자들을 가리켜요. John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony, 그리고 Richard Holt의 1969년 논문에서
이 예제가 처음 설명되었어요. 사실 그들은
게임으로 설명하지 않았고, 이 예제를
CHSH 게임이 아니라 CHSH 부등식이라고
부르는 것이 꽤 흔해요.
하지만 저 같은 컴퓨터 과학자에게는
게임으로 설명하는 것이 매우 자연스러워요.
게임의 수학적 추상화가 중요하고 유용하다는 것은
이미 말씀드렸고, 게임에는 많은 다른 범주가 있어요.
고려할 수 있는 범주가요. CHSH 게임은
비국소 게임이라는 종류의 게임의 한 예예요.
비국소 게임의 일반적인
설정은 이래요.
두 명의 플레이어, Alice와 Bob이 팀으로 협력해요.
함께 이기거나 함께 져요.
이것은 이기적으로 행동할 동기가 없다는 뜻이에요.
순수하게 경쟁적인 제로섬 게임의
정반대 극단이에요.
여기서 게임은 순수하게 협력적이에요.
심판이라는 세 번째 존재가 있어요.
심판은 게임의 플레이어가 아니라 게임을
운영해요. 사실, 비국소 게임의 특정 인스턴스의 명세와
심판의 명세를 동등한 것으로
생각할 수 있어요.
Alice와 Bob에게 부과되는 매우 중요한 제약이 있는데,
게임이 시작되면 서로 통신하는 것이 금지된다는 거예요.
사전에 원하는 전략에 대해 합의할 수 있지만,
게임 자체 중에는 통신이 허용되지 않아요.
원한다면 게임이 일종의 보안 시설에서 진행된다고
상상할 수 있어요. 심판이 형사의 역할을 하고
Alice와 Bob은 경찰서의 다른 방에 있는
용의자라고 상상할 수 있어요. 하지만 설정을 생각하는 또 다른 방법은
Alice와 Bob이 아주 먼 거리에
떨어져 있고, 빛의 속도가 통신을 허용하지 않기 때문에 통신이 금지된다는 거예요.
충분히 빨리요. 예를 들어 Alice가 Bob에게
메시지를 보내려고 하면, Bob이 받을 때쯤 게임은 이미 끝나 있을 거예요.
비국소 게임이 작동하는 방식은 먼저
심판이 Alice와 Bob 모두에게 질문을 해요.
Alice의 질문은 X로, Bob의 질문은
Y로 표시해요.
일반적으로 X와 Y를 원하는 어떤 고전 상태든
될 수 있다고 생각할 수 있고, CHSH 게임의 경우에는
X와 Y는 비트예요.
Alice와 Bob은 그런 다음 답을 제공해야 해요.
Alice의 답은 A로, Bob의 답은 B로 표시해요.
다시, 이 답들은 일반적으로 고전 상태로 볼 수 있고,
질문과 마찬가지로 CHSH 게임에서는 비트예요.
이 시점에서 심판이 결정을 내려요.
Alice와 Bob은 답의 쌍 A, B가 심판이 물어본
질문의 쌍 X, Y에 대해 올바른 것으로
판정되는지에 따라 이기거나 져요. 이에 대해 잠시 후에 좀 더 말씀드릴게요.
먼저, 심판을 자세히 살펴보면서
비국소 게임에서 Alice와 Bob에게 무엇이 도전적인지 이해해 봐요.
비국소 게임을 잠재적으로 도전적으로 만드는 것은
심판이 무작위성을 사용하여 질문 X와 Y를 선택할 수 있다는 거예요.
그것은 Alice와 Bob이 불확실성을 가진다는 뜻이에요.
어떤 질문을 받을지 미리 모르고, 아마 더 중요한 것은
상대방이 어떤 질문을 받았는지 모르고,
통신할 수 없다는 사실과 결합된 그 불확실성이 도전을 만드는 거예요.
형사가 다른 방에 있는 두 용의자를
심문하는 상황과 비슷해요. 용의자들이
상대방에게 어떤 질문이 되는지 모르면,
유죄일 경우 진술을 일관되게 유지하기가 훨씬 어려워요.
방금 심판이 Alice와 Bob이
올바르게 또는 올바르지 않게 답했는지
받은 질문에 따라 결정한다고
말했어요.
이 결정은 어떤 고정된 규칙에 따라 이루어진다고
가정해요. 원하는 어떤 규칙이든 고려할 수 있지만,
Alice와 Bob이 그 규칙을 알고 있다고
가정해요. 적어도 올바르게 답할 기회는 있어야 하니까요.
잠시 후에 CHSH 게임의 규칙을 살펴볼 건데,
다른 규칙을 고려하면 비국소 게임의 다른 예가 될 거예요.
일부 비국소 게임은 흥미롭고 사실 일부는 오늘날까지도
꽤 매혹적이고 신비로운 것도 있고, 일부는 그리 흥미롭지 않아요.
그것이 비국소 게임
모델의 본질이에요.
어쨌든, 심판을 설명하는 데 필요한 두 가지는 이래요.
질문이 정확히 어떻게 선택되는지
그리고 각 가능한 질문 쌍에 대해
어떤 답 쌍이 올바른지예요.
이 두 가지에 대한 설명이 있으면,
심판에 대한 설명이 있는 거고, 그것이 효과적으로
비국소 게임의 인스턴스를
설명하는 거예요.
이제 구체적으로 CHSH 게임을
살펴봐요.
게임이 정의되는 방식, 즉 동등하게
심판이 정의되는 방식은 다음과 같아요.
먼저, 이미 언급했듯이 질문과 답은 모두 비트예요.
심판은 비트 X를 Alice에게, 비트 Y를 Bob에게 보내요.
그리고 각각 비트로 응답해요.
Alice는 A로, Bob은 B로 응답해요.
심판이 어떤 질문을 할지 선택하는 방식은
간단해요. 균일하게 무작위로 선택해요.
질문 쌍 X, Y가 네 가지 가능성, 0-0, 0-1,
1-0, 1-1 중 어느 것이든 동일한 확률이에요.
마지막으로, 어떤 답이 이기고 어떤 답이 지는지를
결정하는 규칙은, 답 쌍 A, B가 질문 쌍 X, Y에 대해 올바른 것은
A와 B의 배타적 논리합이 X와 Y의 논리곱과 같을 때만이에요.
여기 보이는 것처럼 표 형태로 조건을
표현하면 좀 더 이해하기 쉬울 수 있어요.
첫 번째 열에는 네 가지 가능한 질문 쌍이 있고,
두 번째 열에는 Alice와 Bob이 이기기 위해
A와 B에 요구되는
조건이 있어요.
처음 세 경우에서 A와 Y의 논리곱은 0이므로,
배타적 논리합이 0이어야 이길 수 있고,
그것은 A와 B가 같아야 한다는 것과 같은 뜻이에요.
A와 B가 비트이니까요. 네 번째 경우에서는
X와 Y의 논리곱이 1이므로 A와 B의 배타적 논리합이
1이어야 Alice와 Bob이 이기고,
그것은 A와 B가
달라야 한다는 것과 같아요.
이것이 CHSH 게임이에요. 이제 Alice와 Bob의
다른 가능한 전략과 이 게임에서 얼마나 잘할 수 있는지 생각해 볼 수 있어요.
먼저 결정론적 전략에 대해 생각해 봐요.
Alice의 답 A가 받은 질문 X의 함수이고, 마찬가지로 Bob의 답 B가
받은 질문 Y의 함수인
전략이에요.
그리고 밝혀진 바로는, 어떤 결정론적 전략도
매번 이길 수는 없어요.
이것을 추론하는 한 가지 방법은 모든 가능한
결정론적 전략을 하나씩 살펴보고, 그 중 모든 것이
네 가지 가능한 질문 쌍 중 적어도
하나에서 진다는 것을 확인하는 거예요.
Alice와 Bob 각각 선택할 수 있는 함수가 네 개 있고,
레슨 1에서 그 네 가지 함수를 봤으니까, 총 16가지를 확인하면 돼요.
또 다른 방법은 화면에 있는 방정식에 대해
생각하는 거예요. A와 B가 각각 X와 Y의 함수인
결정론적 전략에 대해
생각하고 있어요.
예를 들어, A(0)은 질문 X가 0일 때
Alice의 답이고, A(1)은 질문 X가 1일 때 Alice의 답을
나타내요.
이것이 네 가지 경우 각각에서
이기는 조건이 충족되려면 참이어야 하는 네 개의 방정식이에요.
예를 들어, X가 0이고 Y가 0이면,
A와 B의 배타적 논리합이 0이어야 하고,
X가 1이고 Y가 1인 경우에는
A와 B의 배타적 논리합이 1이어야 해요.
이 방정식들이 모두 참이 되도록 함수 A와 B를 선택할
수 있는 방법이 없다는 것을 보는 한 가지 방법은, 단순히 모든 방정식의 배타적 논리합을 취하는 거예요.
어떤 이진 값과 자기 자신의 배타적 논리합은 0이니까,
좌변의 배타적 논리합은
0이라는 결론이 나와요. A(0)이 두 번,
A(1)이 두 번,
B(0)이 두 번, B(1)이
두 번 나타나니까요.
그래서 모두 XOR하면 최종 답은 0이지만,
방정식의 우변의 배타적 논리합을 취하면
0이 아니라 1이에요. 그래서 네 방정식이
모두 참일 수는 없어요. 적어도 하나는 틀려야 하고
그것은 네 가지 경우 중 적어도 하나에서
Alice와 Bob이 지게 된다는 거예요.
심판이 균일하게 질문을 선택하기 때문에,
결정론적 전략을 사용하여 Alice와 Bob이 이길 확률은
최대 4분의 3 즉 75%예요.
Alice와 Bob이 4분의 3의 확률로 이길 수 있다는 것은
꽤 쉽게 알 수 있어요. 예를 들어 Alice와 Bob이 항상 0으로 답하면
네 번 중 세 번
맞출 거예요.
그래서 Alice와 Bob은 결정론적 전략으로
75% 이상 이길 수 없어요.
하지만 확률적 전략은 어떨까요?
확률적 전략을 사용해도 전혀 도움이 안 돼요.
왜냐하면 모든 확률적 전략은
결정론적 전략의 무작위 선택으로 대안적으로
볼 수 있기 때문이에요. 확률적 연산을 첫 번째 레슨에서 본 것처럼
결정론적 연산의 무작위 선택으로
볼 수 있는 것과 마찬가지예요.
평균은 최대값보다 결코 크지 않으니까,
확률적 전략이 이기는 면에서
결정론적 전략보다 어떤 이점도 제공하지 않는다는 결론이에요.
이것은 Alice와 Bob의 무작위 선택이 상관된 경우도 포함해요.
그래서, 결론은 4분의 3의 확률로 이기는 것이
결정론적이든 확률적이든 어떤 고전적 전략을 사용해도
Alice와 Bob이 할 수 있는
최선이라는 거예요.
이 시점에서 자연스러운 질문은 Alice와 Bob이
양자 전략을 사용하면 더 잘할 수 있는지인데, 특히
게임을 하기 전에 준비했을 수 있는 얽힌 양자 상태를
공유하면 도움이 될 수 있을까요?
답은 예예요. 가능해요. 그것이 이 예제의
핵심이고, 그래서 흥미로운 거예요.
얽힘을 사용하여 Alice와 Bob이 이 게임에서
어떻게 더 잘할 수 있는지 정확히 살펴봐요.
먼저 해야 할 것은 여기 화면에 보이는 것처럼
각 각도 세타에 대해 양자 상태 벡터 카이 세타를 정의하는 거예요.
카이 세타는 코사인 세타 곱하기 켓 제로
더하기 사인 세타 곱하기 켓 원이에요. 참고로
각도는 라디안으로
생각하고 있어요.
예를 들어, 세타가 파이/4, 즉 45도일 때
얻는 벡터가 여기 있어요.
파이/4의 코사인과 사인은 둘 다 루트 2분의 1이니까,
이것은 그냥 플러스 상태의 다른 이름이에요.
세타가 파이의 3/8일 때의 또 다른 예가 여기 있어요.
혹시 파이의 3/8의 사인과 코사인을
바로 모르신다면, 이 예제에서 실제로
필요한 사인과 코사인 값의 표가 여기 있고
이 특정 벡터에 필요한
것도 포함되어 있어요.
알파와 베타라고 하는 두 각도에 대한 이 벡터들의
내적을 취하고 싶다면, 쉽게 할 수 있어요.
이 벡터들에는 실수 성분만 있으니까
복소 켤레를 걱정할 필요가 없고, 코사인의 곱
더하기 사인의 곱을 얻어요.
소위 각도 덧셈 공식을 사용하여
이것을 간단하게 할 수 있어요.
각도 차이의 코사인이에요. 코사인 함수가
0에 대해 대칭이니까
순서는 사실 중요하지 않아요.
이런 종류의 삼각함수 항등식을 외우고 있지
않더라도 혼자가 아니에요. 하지만 기억할 필요는 없어요.
찾아보면 돼요. 하지만 이것은 실수 단위 벡터 사이의
내적의 기하학적 해석을
벡터 사이의 각도의 코사인으로 생각하면
이해가 돼요.
이 벡터들 중 두 개의 텐서곱과
파이 플러스 상태의 내적을 계산하면 비슷한 표현을 얻는데
분모에 루트 2가
있어요.
이것은 이 예제의 맥락에서 파이 플러스 상태가
처음 나타나는 거예요. 왜 이 특정 내적에 관심이 있는지는
곧 보게 될 거지만, 지금은 이전과 같은 표현을
루트 2로 나눈 것을 얻는다는 것만
관찰하면 되고, 이전처럼
간단하게 할 수 있어요.
다음으로, 여기 보이는 것처럼 각 각도
세타에 대해 유니터리 행렬 U 세타를 정의할 거예요.
이것이 정말 유니터리 행렬인지
확인하는 것은 어렵지 않아요.
인식해야 할 핵심은 벡터 사이 세타가
벡터 사이 세타 더하기 파이/2에 직교한다는 거예요. 이것은 이해가 돼요.
파이/2, 즉 90도만큼 회전하면
직교 벡터를 얻으니까요.
U 세타에 U 세타 대거를 곱하면
항등 행렬을 얻어요.
직관적으로 말하면, 이 행렬이 연산으로서 하는 일은
사이 세타를 켓 제로로, 사이 세타 더하기 파이/2를 켓 원으로 매핑하는 거예요.
이 시점에서 Alice와 Bob의 전략을
설명하는 데 필요한 모든 것이 갖춰졌어요.
먼저, 텔레포테이션과 초고밀도 코딩에서처럼
Alice와 Bob은 e-bit를 공유하는 것으로 시작해요.
Alice는 qubit A를 가지고, Bob은 qubit B를 가지고 있고,
두 qubit가 함께 파이 플러스 상태에 있어요.
Alice의 행동은 다음과 같아요.
심판으로부터 받은 비트 X를 확인하고,
X가 0이면 A에 U 제로를 수행해요.
이것은 U 제로가 항등 행렬이니까 아무것도 하지 않는 것과 같아요.
X가 1이면 A에 U 파이/4를 적용해요.
두 연산 중 하나를 적용한 후,
표준 기저 측정으로 A를 측정하고 결과를 심판에게 보내요.
Bob도 매우 비슷한 일을 해요. 그의 qubit는 물론 B이고,
X 대신 심판으로부터 Y를 받지만
핵심 차이는 유니터리 연산에
다른 각도를 사용한다는 거예요.
Y가 0이면 U 파이/8을 적용하고,
Y가 1이면 U 마이너스 파이/8을 적용해요.
이 각도 선택이 왜 좋은 선택인지는 곧 보게 될 건데,
전혀 명백하지 않아요.
그리고 여기 이 전략을 표현하는
circuit 다이어그램이 있어요.
Bob이 위에 있고 Alice가 이번에는 아래에 있어요.
여기 들어오는 e-bit가 있고
이것은 X와 Y가 무엇인지에 따라
Alice와 Bob이 적용하거나 하지 않을 수 있는 유니터리 gate예요.
이것과 이것에 대해서는 비트 X 또는 비트 Y에 의해
제어되는 gate가 있어요.
그리고 여기 이 두 개는 제어 gate처럼 보이지만
원이 채워지지 않은 것이에요.
이것이 의미하는 것은 제어 비트가 0이면
gate가 수행되고, 제어가 1이면 아무 일도 일어나지 않는다는 거예요.
일반적인 제어 gate와 같지만
제어의 0과 1의 역할이 바뀐 거예요.
그래서, 효과적으로 Bob은 Y가 0이면
이 gate를 수행하고, Y가 1이면 이 gate를 수행해요.
Y가 1이면, 마찬가지로 Alice는 X가 0이면
이 gate를, X가 1이면 이 gate를 수행해요.
이것이 Alice와 Bob의 전략이고,
이제 얼마나 잘 작동하는지 알아내면 돼요.
제가 방금 설명한 양자 전략의 분석을 위해,
이 시점에서 정말 두 가지만 필요해요. 첫째, 유니터리 행렬 U 세타는
여기 보이는 것과 같고,
둘째 이 공식이 있었어요.
벡터 사이 세타의 정의도 더 이상 필요하지 않아요.
이 두 방정식이 필요한 전부예요.
네 가지 경우를 고려해야 해요. 경우 1부터
시작할게요. X가 0이고 Y가 0인 경우예요.
전략을 돌아보면, 이 경우 Alice는 자신의 qubit에
U 제로를 수행하고, Bob은 자신의 qubit에 U 파이/8을 수행한다는 것을 알 수 있어요.
Alice가 아래에 있고 Bob이 위에 있다는 것을
기억하세요. 그래서 그들이 얻는 상태는 이렇게 돼요.
U 세타의 정의에 따라 전개하면,
여기 보이는 이 표현식을 얻어요.
더 이상 전개할 필요가 없어요.
다른 공식이 도와줄 테니까요.
그 공식을 네 개의 항 각각에
적용하면, 이것을 얻어요.
이 시점에서 Alice와 Bob 둘 다 측정하고,
결과의 분포를 설명하는 표가 여기 있어요.
확률을 얻기 위해 계수의 절대값 제곱을 취하는데,
이 경우에는 계수가 모두 실수이니까
계수의 제곱이
돼요.
레슨 앞부분의 사인과 코사인 값과
일부 대칭성을 활용하면, 이 확률들을
마지막 열에서처럼
표현할 수 있어요.
우리가 정말 관심 있는 것은
이길 확률이에요. X와 Y가 둘 다 0인 경우에는
A와 B가 같으면 이기고 A와 B가 같지 않으면 져요.
이 확률들을 계산하면, A와 B가 같을 확률은
이 숫자와 이 숫자의 합인데,
(2 더하기 루트 2) 나누기 4이고,
이것은 약 85%예요.
A와 B가 같지 않을 확률은 (2 빼기 루트 2) 나누기 4이고,
이것은 자연스럽게
방금 계산한 값을 1에서 뺀 것이에요.
이 경우 약 85%의 확률로 이겨요.
세 가지 경우가 더 남았지만,
모두 이것과 매우 비슷해요.
X가 0이고 Y가 1인 경우,
Bob은 U 파이/8 대신 U 마이너스 파이/8을 적용해요.
공식의 값들이 다소 바뀌지만,
이전 경우와 정확히 같은 확률을 얻게 돼요.
X가 0이고 Y가 1일 때, Alice와 Bob은 여전히
A와 B가 같을 때 이기니까 정확히 같은 이길 확률을
이전과 같이 가져요.
세 번째 경우, X가 1이고 Y가 0일 때도
비슷한 상황이에요. 각도가 다르지만 정확히
같은 관계를 가지고 있어서, 사실
이전 경우와 정확히 같은 벡터를 얻어요.
그래서 확률도 같고 이길 확률도 같아요.
마지막 경우는 예상할 수 있듯이 조금 다른데,
이 경우에는 이기는 조건이 다르기 때문이에요.
X와 Y가 둘 다 1일 때, Alice와 Bob은
A와 B가 다르면 이겨요.
기본 방법은 같지만 각도가 달라요.
이번에는 이 벡터를 얻게 되고
필요한 뺄셈을 해보면 확인할 수 있어요.
확률이 드디어 바뀌고, 필요한 값을 찾아보면
확률이 효과적으로 이전과
위치가 바뀐 것을 알 수 있어요. 이번에는
A가 B와 같지 않을 확률이 둘 중 더 큰 거예요.
하지만 이 경우에는 Alice와 Bob이
A와 B가 같지 않을 때 이기니까 좋은 거예요.
그래서 다시, 약 85%의 확률로
이겨요.
모든 경우에서 같은 확률로 이기고,
그것은 (2 더하기 루트 2) 나누기 4, 약 85%이니까
그것이 전체적으로
이길 확률이에요.
이것은 어떤 고전적 전략보다 이 게임에서 더 잘하는 것이고,
그래서 흥미로운 거예요.
이것은 어떤 양자 전략에 대해서도
최적의 이길 확률이에요. 어떤 얽힌 상태를 사용해도 이보다 더 잘할 수 없어요.
이 사실은 Tsirelson 부등식으로 알려져 있어요.
이것을 처음 증명한 Boris Tsirelson의 이름을 딴 것이고, 제가 아는 한
이 예제를 게임으로 설명한 최초의 사람 중 한 명이에요.
방금 한 분석이 약간 신비하게 느껴진다면,
기하학적으로 생각하는 것이 가능한데,
각도 선택에 대한 더 나은 감각을 얻는 데 도움이 될 수 있어요.
구체적으로, 여기 보이는 공식을 사용하면,
이미 찾은 내적 표현식에서
쉽게 도출할 수 있는데, 다른 가능한
측정 결과의 확률을 대안적으로 표현할 수 있어요.
네 가지 경우에서 다음과 같아요. 먼저 X, Y가 0, 0이면,
이것이 다양한 측정 결과의 확률이에요.
우리의 공식을 사용하여 그렇게 결론 내리려면
방금 한 분석을 돌아보거나 다시 살펴봐야 해요.
여기에서 이전처럼 그려진 다른 상태 벡터를
볼 수 있어요. 여기서 색상 코드는 파란색이
결과 0에 해당하고 빨간색이
결과 1에 해당해요.
파란색 벡터 사이의 각도와 빨간색 벡터
사이의 각도가 상대적으로 작다는 것을 볼 수 있어요.
두 경우 모두 파이/8이에요. 그래서 코사인이
상대적으로 크고, 두 결과가 같을 확률이
상대적으로 크다는 뜻이에요.
X, Y가 0, 1인 경우에도 비슷한 상황이에요.
같은 색상의 벡터 사이의 각도가 작으니까
같은 결과의 확률이
다시 상대적으로 커요.
세 번째 경우도 비슷하고, 네 번째 경우
X, Y가 1, 1일 때는 흥미로운 일이 일어나요. 이번에는 그냥
이 벡터들이 선택된 방식 때문에,
같은 색상의 벡터 사이의 각도가
상대적으로 크다는 것을 볼 수 있어요.
구체적으로 두 경우 모두 파이의 3/8이에요.
이것은 측정 결과가 같을 확률이 상대적으로
작다는 뜻이지만, 이것은 Alice와 Bob이
답이 다를 때 이기는 유일한
경우이니까 우리가 원하는 거예요.
다시 한번 벡터들이에요. X, Y가 0, 0일 때,
X, Y가 0, 1일 때,
X, Y가 1, 0일 때,
그리고 X, Y가 1, 1일 때예요.
이 기하학적 그림이 이 전략이
어떻게 작동하는지에 대한 직관을 형성하는 데
도움이 되고, 이 다양한 각도가
왜 그렇게 선택되었는지 이해하는 데 도움이 될 수 있어요.
레슨을 마무리하면서, CHSH 게임에 대한
간단한 몇 가지 말씀을 할게요.
먼저, 이미 언급했듯이, 이 예제가
항상 게임으로 설명되는 것은 아니에요.
예를 들어, 물리학 커뮤니티에서는 이 예제를
게임이 아니라 단순히 실험으로 설명하는 것이 더 흔하고
Alice와 Bob은 플레이어가 아니라
검출기로 여겨져요.
이와 같은 실험에서 얽힘이 어떤 고전적 설명과도
일치하지 않는 통계적 결과를 이끌어낸다는 기본 아이디어는,
더 일반적으로 소위 국소 숨은 변수에 기반한
어떤 이론과도 일치하지 않는데, 벨 상태의 이름인 John Bell에 의한 것이에요.
그래서 사람들은 이런 종류의 실험을
벨 테스트라고 자주 불러요.
사람들은 또한 벨의 정리를 언급하기도 하는데,
다양한 방식으로 공식화할 수 있지만, 기본적으로 양자역학이
소위 국소 숨은 변수 이론과
양립할 수 없다고 말해요.
CHSH 게임 또는 부등식은 본질적으로
벨 테스트의 매우 깔끔한 예이고,
이 예제를 벨의 정리의 증명이나
시연으로 생각할 수 있어요.
두 번째 말씀은 CHSH 게임이 양자 정보 이론이
정확한 이론인지 실험적으로 검증하는 한 가지 방법을 제공한다는 거예요.
CHSH 게임을 구현하는 실험을 실제로 설정할 수 있어요.
제가 방금 설명한 것과 같은 얽힘에 기반한
전략을 포함해서요. 그리고 작동하는지 볼 수 있는데, 작동해요.
이것은 얽힘이 실재한다는 높은 수준의
확신을 제공하고, 얽힘을 설명하기 위해
생각해 내는 모호하거나 시적인 방법들과 달리,
CHSH 게임 또는 실험은 구체적이고
검증 가능한 방법으로 얽힘을 관찰할 수 있게 해요.
그것이 중요하게 들린다면,
실제로 중요하기 때문이에요. 2022년 노벨 물리학상이 바로 이것을 인정해요.
이 상은 Alain Aspect, CHSH의 C인
John Clauser, 그리고 Anton Zeilinger에게 수여되었어요.
얽힌 광자를 이용한 실험으로 벨 부등식의
위반을 확립한 것, 다시 말해서 제가 설명한 것과 같은 양자 전략이
실제로 작동하고 고전적 전략을 능가한다는 것을 보여준 것에 대해서예요.
이에 대해 더 알고 싶으시다면, 제 동료
Olivia Lanes의 벨의 정리에 대한 영상을 확인해 보시길 권해요.
바로 여기 Qiskit YouTube 채널에 있어요.
마지막으로, 비국소 게임이라는 주제는 더 일반적으로
정말 매혹적이고 활발한 연구 분야예요.
물리학, 컴퓨터 과학, 순수 수학을 결합하는 분야이고,
비국소 게임에 대해 아직도
오늘날까지 답이 나오지 않은 많은
흥미로운 질문들이 남아 있어요.
이것으로 레슨 4가 끝났고, 양자 정보의 기초에 대한
시리즈의 유닛 1도 끝이에요.
첫 번째 레슨은 고립된 단일 시스템에 대해
양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지 설명했고, 두 번째 레슨은 양자 정보가
다중 시스템에 대해 어떻게 작동하는지 설명했는데,
이것은 단일 시스템에 대해 작동하는 방식에서 자연스럽게 나와요.
세 번째 레슨은 quantum circuit 계산 모델을
소개했고, 네 번째 레슨에서는 얽힘으로 할 수 있는 것을 보여주는
세 가지 중요한 예제를
살펴봤어요.
그 과정에서 텐서곱과 내적을 포함한
매우 중요한 수학적 개념들을 봤고,
양자 정보의 근본적인
한계들을 관찰했어요.
시리즈의 다음 유닛에 함께해 주시길 바라요.
양자 알고리즘에 관한 것으로, 양자 정보가 제공하는
계산적 이점이 무엇인지에
초점을 맞출 거예요.
그때까지 안녕히 계세요.